this presentation is an adaptation of a
talk that I have given at the UN Rotary
Club World Peace conference last month
and the idea is to really just give you
a big picture of what the Khan Academy's
is what it is this is what most people
associated with it or or or I guess
what's gotten the most notoriety we have
800 videos and for the most part it's
mathematics but it really covers
mathematics finance economics has a good
section on on physics and the genesis of
this well III joke that it you know I
should I should dedicate this to my
wife's residency because there were a
lot of weekends where she was working
all night and I really felt guilty doing
anything but recording maybe math videos
or possibly cleaning the house or
cooking dinner but the genesis of this I
mean that definitely did enable it and
so it's not really that much of a joke
but the genesis of this was me
tutoring my cousin Nadia when she came
and visited me after my wedding this was
in the summer of o4 she was exiting
sixth grade she was entering in a middle
school and the middle school placement
test they put her in kind of the you
know I they put her in I guess you
called the remedial math class and you
know we all know that if you get put
into remedial math class and early age
that you know they track you and then
you'll never end up in algebra and then
you know it's pretty much at sixth grade
that are signing your fate and you'll
never end up you know becoming a doctor
or an engineer not that you have to but
they essentially shut your doors down
very quickly and she was hard-working
she's a smart girl when I talked to her
she was more mature than most people her
age
so I said Nadia if you're willing I'm
willing to work with you every day after
I come home from work I'm from New
Orleans she lived in New Orleans they
were visiting me in Boston at the time
and she agreed so every day I would come
home from work we would get on Yahoo
doodle and we'd have a screen that
looked something like this although this
is a screenshot of a of a khanacademy
actual video but and and we both had
tablet I got her a little note a little
tablet thing that she could draw with
and we would draw and we would have a
conference call we would have a tutoring
session for about an hour a day and the
first month was kind of difficult she
would so demoralized by you know math
math classes but after a little work she
really got a excited about it and anyone
who's tutoring their own kids my my one
recommendation is don't just tutor so
that someone catches up or so that they
they're barely staying with their math
class tutor someone so that they catch
up and that they actually start learning
ahead of their math class because then
it just really changes a one's whole
self perception and and you know I can't
emphasize enough how important self
perception actually is especially in
things like in like in mathematics but
anyway she did really well and I started
tutoring her brothers Arman and Ally and
then other family friends and then just
the coordination became difficult I
wanted them to do problems that they you
know I could track what they were doing
so that's where the web app came into
into effects I'll talk more about that
later but to make a long story short
I've started putting up videos on
YouTube and said you know with Nadia I
could do it live but then you know for
the next five kids who wanted to learn
linear equations I would just make a
linear equations video and I kept doing
that and just on a whim I made it public
and a bunch of kids just started
watching you know at first I put a video
up and I get excited that you know 20 20
kids would watch a video and um and then
obviously things have have picked up
beyond that and it really seems like I
kind of struck a chord and on a lot of
levels I you know I'd like to take
credit for it all but to some degree a
lot of this happened by chance
YouTube initially before I was a partner
had a 10-minute had a 10-minute limit on
my videos and in hindsight that was
actually kind of the most digestible
nugget of knowledge that you could take
we've all sat in 90-minute lectures and
you really can't pay attention for more
than ten minutes of time without a break
and in ten minutes really is the perfect
amount of time to digest one concept and
and it just becomes really high heat
high value for everyone involved by the
way I started putting things on YouTube
kids all over the world started watching
and slowly started growing I mean now
it's it it's it's been growing quite
rapidly if you look at this chart this
is actually the viewership it's been
growing I estimated about 20 percent a
month this little spike right here where
right now it close to twenty thousand
viewers this spike right here is a
whoops I mean is using the right tool
let me change my pen color to yellow
just because I'm bored of the blue
so this bike right here that is a a
video I did on the the Geithner plan
that on essentially how how the banks
could use it to game the system and that
kind of went pseudo viral so that really
piqued my viewership at thirty thousand
views but and actually that's an
interesting coming you know a lot of
people have you started with Nadia and
her problem with school how did I end up
doing finance and economics well my day
job is I I'm a you know a research
analyst and I essentially invest money
and I paid close to tabs on the economy
for a living and I'd go to the parties
and people would ask me about the credit
crisis and the economy in the housing
market and I said you know what I'll
also make videos for you and so that's
not that started but that's where this
peak came in a couple of it's just
interesting to analyze where this where
everything came in from but we're
averaging about twenty thousand it's
growing really fast and we're already
about 10 times the viewership we were a
year ago and hopefully tenth you know
we'll be at 200 thousand views per day
a year from now and you know it's I
think it's just a matter for awareness
cuz it's you know we haven't done any
advertising or anything just because
it's it's just me anyway and so you know
how people say where you're going with
this right now we already cover you know
this is pretty much all of K through 12
I have to build a little bit more on
kind of the I would say the K through
fourth-grade concepts but really
everything that's covered in high school
mathematics is covered on the Khan
Academy already and on my to-do list I
have to build out the statistics the
statistics playlists but I want to do
chemistry in biology but the eventual
goal is to do literally everything I'm
doing these because I think this is
where there's a lot of high value and a
lot of people are struggling with these
even though I'd argue that it you know
hopefully they shouldn't have to
yeah but eventually I want to cover
grammar and philosophy and the law and
you know really build out finance or
whatever the idea is you could get an
education online for free that says of a
pretty good quality not to harp on this
slide too much but I I even argue that I
am a better tutor on video than I am
live because I you know no matter who
you're getting tutoring instruction from
there's this notion of when it's live
it's there's kind of the stress and if I
ask you do you understand it you want to
yes even though you really don't cuz you
feel bad about using up my time and
maybe people get frustrated and get
shows up in their voice but what it's a
video you can pause it you can watch it
when you have energy you don't have to
coordinate with the other people it's
you know it's just on your own time you
can pause it you don't have to take
notes you don't have to say what if I
forget this before the exam it's just a
much better overall format to do
instruction and so I even you know even
family friends who I'd still do tutor
directly I still argue that they they're
probably enjoyed my videos more than
they'd enjoy me but anyway with that
said let me go to the next slide how do
I go let's see page down no that doesn't
work this is I don't know let's let me
see maybe I should just draw the go to
the cursor oh there there you go let me
go now go back to the drawing tool and
just so you know this drawing tool was
given out of the blue one of the viewers
said you need a better a better screen
recording tool his name is Mohammed I
don't I don't know who he is or ever he
literally gave me this $300 application
which is you know it's another Testament
I don't know it's it's it's kind of it's
it's overwhelming how many people have
reached out and have been helping out
and kind of making this effort work
maybe III this slide is just kind of a
subset of the comments that a lot of the
viewers have made and I do this slide
you know I had mixed feelings about it
because it is a little bit of self horn
Tooting but you know when I go to
parties and they've never seen Khan
Academy and I say you know in my spare
time I like to make videos people kind
of like oh you know that's nice it's
probably a nice cute little hobby and
you know online videos and you know what
impact can it really be having but when
you read the the kind of the stories
that people are right on the on our
message boards everyday you I think it's
it's pretty apparent that this is having
a pretty significant impact these most
of these are really from the last the
last week or two and we get about 30 or
40 letters and comments a day and you
know and that's a subset of I think the
people who are actually having impact
but you know this one you know when I
read stuff like this I don't care what
happens to the rest of my day it puts
you in a good mood you know
I really like to enjoy your videos
that's core not me it's just nice to get
that but you know I was born with the
learning disabilities and your video has
dramatically helped me understand my
math because of your videos I became the
top student in my grade 11 University
the way he he or she is saying I guess
there's a video of Mike so the way
they're saying you know my top student
my grade 11 university level math class
it sounds like they might be in in a in
a in a for either either the United
Kingdom over for former colony of it
because you know grade 11 we'd always
say 11th grade but anyway yeah that's
heartwarming and and it's amazing
because you know who knows which videos
he or she watched but once they were
done they were done and I you know this
this required no incremental time on my
part no incremental time no incremental
expense but he or she really got I mean
I'm I'd like to think almost you know a
life-changing benefit from from these
videos and that's another thing I'd like
to point out these videos you know every
well out there's a lot of blogs and
videos but there's nothing better than
actual education content cuz it never
goes old I mean I always joke why are
there all these textbooks that they have
to republish them when you know calculus
hasn't changed that much since Newton so
you recorded once and that the the it
lasts forever you know the it's yeah I
get excited about the idea that maybe a
hundred years from now my great-great
grandkids could be learning or your
great-great grandkids could be learning
calculus from me and that's just you
know maybe it's a it's a well anyway you
know these are these are the other
things you know what great job I knew I
was not as senseless as the professor
thought and and I want to highlight that
because I think we've all felt anger at
some point in our you know whether it
was anger at our self or anger at the
teacher or anger at the system and and
frankly you know if these are the sensor
argue some of the some of the positive
feedback we get people are kind of angry
because they're angry good because
because the system had told them that
they didn't understand things or the
system had told them that you know they
can't be an engineer or they can't be a
doctor they should just you know look
someplace else and then when they look
at the videos they're like what you know
that that really wasn't that bad and
it's almost an anger and realizing where
people were trying to you know go you
know this is you know you rock well
thank you
comedy owns this was three weeks ago you
know I without your videos I'd be
failing math and school so once again
you know I didn't do anything I just
recorded this who knows which videos
he's watching but it was it was a while
ago you know these are great I've never
seen complicated topics explained so
beautifully and you know I when I know
this is self horn tooting and I feel a
little awkward about it but I want to
just make this point because the whole
you know sometimes when I talk to
educators about Thursday they say what
curriculum are you using and I said well
I'm not using any curriculum I'm
explaining math as it is in my brain and
you know I've had the privilege in life
of being able to learn math I think at a
fairly deep level and you know if if I
bump into a math problem in my everyday
life I I have retained a lot of it so I
just I just explain it you know if I I
have a bunch of math neurons that are
all connecting to each other and I
explain I try to explain math as it's in
my brain I think I've kind of stumbled
on a more natural methodology because if
it really ought is all in one person's
brain it's not this artificial construct
made by you know bureaucrats at some
state level or someone who made a
textbook who just wanted to fill pages
so that they could you know the textbook
would weigh more and give kids hernias
and they could charge more for it it's
really just you know a very natural
expression of what do you need to know
and what do you need to connect and and
you know one problem I've always had
with math instruction and this used to
kind of frustrate me structure eight
frustrate me seeing a lot of my
classmates get frustrated when I was in
school was just this notion of you know
a lot of times they teach the same thing
in a hundred different ways they make it
complicated and kids or kids are just
taught that you know this is very
complex but they're really just teaching
the same thing in a hundred different
ways and using a hundred different words
and just and not connecting the dots for
students and and that's what we're
trying to do it at the Khan Academy but
anyway this is you know yeah I think
this gives you a good context of you
know you explain everything as if we
were five years old but it's still not
boring or but very interesting I think
that's because I'm I'm a little bit
flippant in some of some of my videos I
sometimes answer the phone and talk to
him
well anyway anyway so this is you know
let's see this is you know differential
equations and you know and this is one
thing I want to highlight because there
are other efforts that are that are
making videos out there and
and they all deserve credit and you know
I went to MIT and MIT I was especially
proud the first time they announced
their OpenCourseWare a project because
you know this was at the same time that
a lot of other educational universe
institutions and I'll say educational in
in quotes because a lot of these
institutions at the time we're talking
about charging for the content and
starting virtual schools and essentially
kind of keeping the barriers to
knowledge hi while MIT just went out
there said you know what we're just
gonna record all of our lectures and
offer them free to the world and you
know I had never been more proud of my
of my where I went to school than that
day but I think the the problem and this
has a lot of value I mean I still look
at these videos when I want to review of
some of the really advanced topics that
you know I had learned at one time but
the problem with these is these are just
videos of what goes on in a standard
classroom you know and you could talk
about you know what the quality of
lecture is there are some great ones and
some not-so-great ones but it's not
taking advantage of the real advantage
that that on-demand video really has you
know one that notion that you have this
this 10-minute granularity that I talked
about or the notion that you can pause
and replay or that you know you should
just be able to narrow and exactly what
you don't know MIT it's a tremendously
valuable resource but I think it could
be special purpose to be a little better
and then the other thing is of course
it's it's only addressing at the
university level it doesn't really touch
on K through 12 we're really there is a
much bigger need and I'll talk more
about that in a little bit so you know
this is just some more this is actually
some comments from one of the actual
from one of the actual message but I
think is from calculus you know you've
given me so much confidence and and I
want to highlight that because math is
all about confidence I mean if you think
about math is just a bunch of concepts
let me find a darker color here math is
all about you know if this is one
concept this is another concept and you
know that concept leads to a couple of
more concepts and those concepts lead to
a couple of other concepts and if you
either get demoralized here or you just
don't have a hundred percent mastery of
this concept right here I don't care how
smart you
I don't care how great a teacher you
have over here you're never going to
have master here because math math is
cumulative and the problem is in our in
our system right now is that you know we
expect a student who was a B+ student
here to somehow be at least a B+ student
here or even an A student here while you
know if they were B+ student here the
rest of the time they're never gonna be
a B+ student in fact more probably
they're just gonna degrade over time
because they're gonna have these gaps in
their knowledge that just become more
and more pronounced as you go you know
further down the learning curve and the
problem is a lot of people get here
let's say that this is algebra and
they're smart hardworking they have a
great teacher who's you know everything
that a teacher should be and and and the
teacher gets frustrated the kid gets
demoralized the kid starts thinking that
he or she isn't intelligent cuz they're
just not getting the algebra and maybe
even that you know and they're like this
is a good teacher and I'm still not
getting it but the problem is they would
have gotten the algebra if they just
understood maybe negative numbers
properly and the problem is that the
student either might not be aware that
they have that weakness there they that
they misunderstood something at a very
early level or they're just afraid to
tell their algebra teacher that you know
what I actually it's not the algebra
mapping trouble with I'm having trouble
with something that I really should have
learned 2 3 4 even 5 years ago and I'll
talk more about it but we've been
working with some groups of students
where they you know they're there are
learning algebra but their weaknesses
were really basic and once they got over
those really basic weaknesses they
really just accelerated ahead and these
are students that we probably a lot of
people probably would have labeled as
you know slow or not good at math but
once they got over those basic
weaknesses they were really as good as
as anybody and this is actually one of
my favorite comments you know and and I
think this kind of says it all in terms
of self confidence you know I actually
got a natural high and a good mood for
the entire day since I remember seeing
all of this matrix text so I'm assuming
you know we've all sat in a math class
or you see stuff on the board just like
well I don't know what that is matrix
text in class and here I'm all like I
know kung fu I think it's tremendously
empowering when you actually when you
actually get something and you know I
fundamentally believe that everyone
loves learning they just don't like
being frustrated they don't like being
talked down to and they don't like being
told that there you know not as smart or
being demoralized you know this is a you
know this is a and yeah this is another
value of the videos it's just the notion
of of homeschooling
and so you know this this whoops I
thought I was using a different tool so
let me see if I can I don't want to do
it that dog right away that serves a
purpose so this is a this is a letter
from a home schooler and that's another
value I think of the videos but you know
I use video teaching whenever possible
homeschooling three children local forum
where I post materials something I've
never run your videos before this was a
while this was in December I'm very
familiar with an incredible number of
videos teachers how for your videos
stand head and shoulders above all of
them that you know I'm I guess that's
horn Tooting but you know I thank you
you speak so clear at whatever my eldest
kid is dancing around the room here
because she's so excited that she found
someone the taught like this and you
know I yeah I don't want to I feel
uncomfortable I mean this is kind of
boasting and I apologize for that I
don't want to appear that way but IIIi
wanted a highlight just that this is I
mean when someone is empowered
especially in something like mathematics
I mean they want a dance anyway let me
move on so this is I mean it has gotten
some notoriety and I really just wanted
to show this because it's you know
there's a couple of funny anecdotes here
CNN actually picked up on on the whole
Khan Academy thing because I I told you
already I made those videos on the
credit crisis and when the whole tarp
emergency was going on they said that
people in their studio were actually
watching and I think to you know before
explaining it themselves so they wanted
me on they had you know to really
explain what was going on at the tarp so
you know I was and they and and their
big thing they actually wanted me to do
it the way I do it on YouTube so this is
actually a screenshot from the scenes
the the CNC sorry the the CNN showing so
they actually had me on there and I was
in the San Francisco office and and and
and Rick Sanchez when Atlanta but it was
fun and and hopefully it was instructive
to some and actually ended up ended up
writing a paper with a Berkeley
professor who thought that our idea to
start a new banks was probably the best
one so if you're interested there's that
paper out there this is an article that
came out in Italy apparently in the
biggest
paper in Milan and the the of how the
the the the author apparently the
journalists he reassured me that there
was a huge following of the Khan Academy
in Italy which was a little bit
surprising it I I do track where it's
being washed and it seems like it's
mainly and you know the english-speaking
world former British colonies I'd say
you know it's popular in the US and the
UK and India and Australia but I guess
you know the Italians you know I
obviously don't do them in Italian so I
that's just a neat thing actually I
didn't have to read this this might say
that you know this guy is the biggest
loser on earth but I think the
journalist seemed like a nice guy so I'm
assuming that they didn't they didn't
they didn't ruin my reputation in Italy
anyway they showed up in in USA today
you know the the here the the
journalists had told me that they knew a
lot of kids at the local college I think
this is she's one of them who were kind
of dependent on these videos to get
through their math classes but I just
thought that wasn't interesting this is
something that you know I I had thought
about this when first making the web app
and making the videos that you know
there's a value of these videos
especially I was thinking more in terms
of underprivileged areas of the US you
know I went to a a public school that
was you know we you know I've I'm
familiar with kind of the broad spectrum
of Education I've had the privilege of
going to some of you know the best
universities and but at the same time
I've also had the privilege of also
seeing what some of the you know what
what the the broad spectrum I don't want
to I don't want to say anything bad
because obviously wherever I went to
school has given me a lot of
opportunities in life but I was
originally thinking that Khan Academy
had a lot of value in kind of the inner
city and places where they didn't
weren't able to attract the best yeah or
not always or you know always have the
best teachers or people with deep
subject knowledge but this came out of
the blue this world possible group right
here this is a group of engineers at
Cisco and they contacted me out of the
blue they were there setting up these
servers they call them you know these
these Rachele servers where they're
essentially putting all the content that
they thought was
Saturday for a self learner to have an
education on these servers and then
taking them they went to Ethiopia and
then taking them into villages that were
not on the internet and and but setting
up these thin clients so that people
could have essentially have an education
and and what they say you know we put a
snapshot of Wikipedia they put the
Gutenberg text projects but they said
you know what we want the Khan Academy
because it really brings it all together
the Khan Academy video so you know I
feel privileged to kind of be in the
same categories Wikipedia cuz I'm uh I'm
a big fan of it but you know they were
very adamant that this is kind of
information and my friend yeah who Jerry
who kind of came who he also contacted
me I didn't know him before you know he
kind of said you know this this stuff
right here is information well this
right here is knowledge and you know
that that is the idea is that a lot of
these villages in Ethiopia and I'll talk
about Uganda in a second even if you
have the resources and obviously the
resources is a huge problem even if you
do have the resources it's tremendously
difficult to find people in villages who
have you know not to even speak of
calculus skills or you know who know
physics but even have you know basic
algebra pre-algebra skills it's almost
impossible so those kids are just left
stranded even if there are the resources
to provide it at least if you have
something like the Khan Academy you have
access to you know we I'd like to think
something close to best-in-class an
instruction a UConnect org is another
organization that's let me go to the
next slide so this is the letter that
literally kind of started the
relationship with you connect this is a
letter from Lisa Stern and you know did
since discovering your site I've
introduced thousands people to do it I
think that your model offers the best
hope for high quality education that can
be given to the masses and so you know
this is one of those letters that after
I read it I read it to my wife and
Cocina sometimes you know I have to give
my wife a lot of credit because she's
put up with a lot especially you know
when the you know even now my our baby's
crying I was like you know I have to do
a video on the normal distribution right
now and you know that that's not an easy
thing to well anyway but you know I read
this to her and you know she gets
excited but you know since discovering
your site I have introduced thousands of
people to do it I think your model
offers the best hope for a high quality
education that King that can be given to
the masses
I know that there's an enormous need for
inspired online teachers I've I have
observed and this is the part that was
really touching you know I have observed
students using your programs when they
listen to you that cannot stop smiling
and I'm ready to try things they never
would have tried if it weren't for your
your brilliant teaching anyway I know
this is a self horn tooting I'm going to
stop but you know this is important but
I believe that every child deserves the
teacher as good as you are so she found
it with her husband this disorganisation
UConnect org in 1996 so they've been
operational for a while set up over 300
schools in Uganda I mean that's that's
no joke with computers which we
connected from banks and businesses in
England and Switzerland so you know
these are people that you know care
about kids care about especially in the
developing world and you know they
they've really just bootstrap this
effort they've actually become a pretty
substantial organization in Europe now
we do everything from collecting packing
and shipping computers with that her
email went on and the crux of it is they
wanted access to Khan Academy but they
explained that a lot of these villages
this is actually obeah in Uganda they
don't have access to the network so what
could they do and I put them in touch
with the guys at Cisco who were the
world possible people and they gave them
a Rachel server and so this is actually
in obeah they actually set up one of
these Rachel servers from the other
organization and I believe these are the
instructors or learning I don't know if
they're doing the Khan Academy right
here but this is essentially what it
what it looks like they have been ramped
up on the Khan Academy and apparently
the Minister of Education who used to be
a math teachers really the Minister of
Education of Uganda is really excited
about what's going on there and you know
this just I mean I don't know this this
to me is kind of one of the coolest
aspects of the Khan Academy because it's
something that I never expected but it
really shows kind of the the leverage
that you know I make if someone makes a
video on and it's a good video on on
teaching a concept and it doesn't just
help kids with a computer and you know
there are these really impressive people
out there that are going into the
villages who can take that same content
and then actually distribute it to
people who really who really could use
it this is so everything I've talked
about right now and I apologize I
sometimes do just you know
I just keep talking some time but it
hopefully gives you some context of
where everything comes from but
everything I talked so far about it was
the Khan Academy
video library but the real Genesis was
the Khan Academy web application and
that's what this is here you know and
initially start literally with you I
wanted I wanted to be able to keep track
of Nadia and Arman you know when they
were doing problems I wanted to be able
to them to be able to do exercises so I
wrote a little JavaScript that made that
essentially dynamically generated
infinite problems and I put a database
behind it so that I could so that I
could keep track of what they were doing
then I then I made it so you know once
they finished one concept instead of
having to kind of keep track of it I
made the system automatically do it and
it turned into this web application and
so this is a screenshot of it and so and
then the videos actually became what
were the idea was to offer the
instruction with the web application so
this is a screenshot of multiplying
decimals and so when a student this was
and literally this web application
starts at one plus one equals two and
I'll talk more about that in a second
but it'll generate a problem on the fly
so it has an infinite number of problems
if it takes the student a thousand if it
takes a student a thousand problems to
figure out how to do something they will
get a thousand problems if they don't
know how to do it they can click hint
right here and every time you click hint
it tells you the next step and it
highlights everything what you know how
did you do that next step and if they're
if they're really like I have no idea of
how to do a problem like this they can
click watch video and then the YouTube
video pops up and hopefully they'll have
a sense of of what they're doing and the
whole idea of this web app is to kind of
close the loop that occurs in in the
standard education model right and the
standard education model you kind of get
a lecture in the classroom you know I'll
talk more about it you know you have to
kind of the teachers no matter how good
they are they have you they have to
teach to kind of a common denominator
half the kids might be lost half the
kids might be bored then you go home and
practice in the current with homework
you don't get any feedback you could be
completely stuck but you're stuck
there's no help there you don't get
feedback until the test which is also
less your assessment and then in the
current model it's time to go the next
concept even if your assessment said you
only got a C and you really should just
focus on what you on the that current
concept so that's the current model what
we're trying to do is kind of close this
loop and allow everyone to learn and at
a self-paced level so let me so this is
so that you know that last video I call
that the instruction video but this is
the practice so once again this is a
more advanced concept this is the slope
of a line and it's very visual when you
click on the hints it actually draws you
know this is the rise is -7 the run is
minus 4 and it tells you how to explain
these show up these pop up as you click
on it and actually you could go I
actually have a on the art YouTube
channel I have a where I do a live demo
of this and you could click watch video
and explain it but the key point here is
that you actually get feedback you it's
not like you're looking in a textbook
and you don't even know how to start if
you don't know how to start you click
hint it explains it to you it's not like
a textbook where you get an answer your
answer is different than the answer the
textbook has there's no context for
where you went wrong there's nothing you
can do and actually you know this is a
streak until the video game it's
actually amazing how many kids actually
get addicted to this energy points but
you can give feedback to the system and
the system uses that on analytics this
is your streak but this is your practice
and feedback and it really all happens
at the same time and then finally we do
assessment we're tracking you know that
you saw those last few screens kids are
doing problems and the system is
tracking everything and I'll in the next
slide I'll show you how granular their
tracking is but this slide I think
really I mean you know I have probably
taken up too much of your time already
but this is the one I really want to
focus in because it highlights I think a
lot of the pitfalls of the current
education system and and the power of
self-paced adaptive learning can have so
this the Khan Academy is is was used as
essentially the core math curriculum at
for the Peninsula bridge which was a
summer program for underprivileged
mainly Latino and African American
students and in in the Bay Area and so
this is the data from one of the sites
so just so you understand this is the
the day's progression in the summer camp
that they were they did this for six
weeks and this is the number of modules
they completed just we have a sense you
know this these first few modules right
here these are like one plus one equals
two up here it's like you know decimals
and things these are things like
negative numbers so as you get more and
more advanced this you know getting up
here this is like this is like
trigonometry this is basic addition
right so we're plotting in this graph
the class is progression as they went
through and this black
right here this is the average of the
class so the average stood in the class
are all working at their own pace it's
interesting you know you can see that
they all advanced really quickly right
here and really fairly quickly here but
then they all the the rate you know the
advance was really fast here and then
the rate was something slower over here
and the sense is and you can there's a
lot of data that bears this out is that
this is when they were kind of reviewing
and this is when they were looking at
new concepts or concepts that it was a
little bit more substantive than a
review they really needed a slightly
deeper understanding but more important
than that just so you had a sense these
little green lines above and beyond
these are one standard deviation above
and and I have videos on their standard
deviation if you forgot where that came
from you know what is the standard
deviation is kind of the average
distance from from the average all right
so this is one standard deviation below
and I want to highlight a couple
students this is Karina and after five
days into the program
she was already one standard deviation
more than one standard deviation below
the average student in the class so for
you if you know Karina was unlucky
enough that there was just an assessment
test that day you would have said Karina
is below average and if the student was
here you said they were above average
maybe Karina like my cousin Nadia she
should be tracked into kind of a slower
class and all of that and then you know
these kids up here they should be put
into a gifted class or whatever you know
these are the kids that are meant to be
physicists these are the kids that are
meant to be you know I don't know a
receptionist and they make all these
judgments and these judgments do matter
I mean we all know that they affect the
rest of your life especially the things
that happen in middle school and in high
school but was powerful here is in a in
a traditional model Karina would have
been tracked and and and she would have
always had this weakness she whatever
this concept was here but then once she
got that concept she was allowed to
learn at her own pace her learning just
accelerated then the next concept she
just she just went straight through and
checked we finished it finished the
class as one of the top students this is
only a period of six weeks who knows
what it might happen in a period of you
know six months or six years but she
actually finished over one standard
deviation above the average actually
Alexander he was close to he was one of
he was definitely below average starting
off so he once again would have been you
know tracked in on kind of a you know
remedial class but he was actually the
top performing student in the class
by the end of the session and this is
also highlights I think a problem no
matter how good of a teacher you you
know you want to be or you can be when
you do the traditional when you do the
traditional learning model you kind of
always have to play with my pen tool
right now you always have to kind of
teach to the norm if you have to do if
this was a lecture right now you would
always have to be kind of teaching at
this pace right whatever this pace is
and when you teach at this pace let me
change the colors when you teach at this
pace all the people who could be
learning all the stuff up here they're
bored and all of these people down here
they're completely lost and they're
getting no benefit of it so to a large
degree there's all at any given moment
of time there's only a small subset of
people that the lecture no matter how
good of a teacher you are you know and
I'm you know I in no way am I trying to
say that you know I mean this would be
my problem if I was in a classroom and I
had to give a lecture of 30 kids
probably 10 would be bored 10 would be
lost and me you know maybe 10 would in
and out become you know vaguely
interested in what I was doing or maybe
just cuz the pace was so slow they would
kind of switch between these two things
and the irony is you can be bored and
one thing and then the next thing you'll
be lost so the class was going too slow
for you and then the class goes too fast
and that's a shame because you could
have learned this real fast and then
spent more time on that right there and
just to hit the point home this is this
is the actual data so I we analyzed
where Karina actually had a problem so
it actually turned out that it was
adding and subtracting negative numbers
was where she had a problem and this is
just gives you an idea of the
granularity we keep track of this is the
first problem she did right now did in
the system on adding and subtracting
negative numbers it took her about 33
seconds red means she got it wrong so
she got a bunch of problems wrong this
took her a long time this is when she
watched the video we kept track of that
and then after she watched the videos we
see that she got a lot better it took
her less time she got a lot more right
blue is means you did the problem right
she got a couple wrong but then she she
was getting the idea I mean maybe this
was a special case she didn't quite get
but then she got ten in a row and that's
how we define proficiency you get ten in
a row this is actually a histogram of of
actually you know the distribution of
how long it takes and we do keep
tract of that too because it is
important to just keep track of how long
someone takes relative to the norm but
just going back to Carina
she had problem with that she was able
to take a little bit more time on that
than what other students took but once
she did that she raced forward like I
said and then this concept right here
level three linear equations that's like
you know minus three X plus seven is
equal to X minus two X minus a so this
is a fairly fairly complex topic she
just raced through it she just got it it
was easy for her I mean you see a
student like this
this kid is meant to be an
astrophysicist this kid that back here
you would have said you would have said
you know maybe you should be a
receptionist or something one day not
not to say that a receptionist is a bad
job but I mean she has a lot of
potential and it and there's millions of
kids like this all around the world who
are getting lost in the system either
because they're not getting access to
good instruction or even with excellent
instruction they're just it's not being
paced with them and if they just get
assessed at the wrong time they're kind
of told that they're not intelligent but
if they get it assessed at the right
time people realize that these really
are brilliant kids so this is a big
picture of just kind of the curriculum
we're doing I talked I spoke in the you
know before that a lot of people say
what is your curriculum and I just do
essentially I think what is you know how
math makes sense to me and every student
will start here at let me use the pen
tool at basic Edition this is literally
one plus one is equal to two as you get
those right it moves you to the next
concept so this right here would be like
you know seven plus eight so you'll get
like a two-digit answer and then so this
will be like fifteen plus nine so it it
incrementally makes things slightly
slightly more difficult and once you
know basic addition then you're ready
for stuff like two minus one and that's
the basic subtraction so it's very
granular in the concept and it's really
making sure that you understand that
exact concept it's fine I had a friend
who was an advising I think he was on
the white he was advising people over on
the white house a panel for education
curriculum and you know they get a bunch
of academics together and they'll talk
about you know and at grade seven
because of you know people should learn
this concept this concept this concept
this concept but he said you know you
should have a know directed graph like
this because
math really any learning isn't linear
like this one concept can lead to a
bunch of other concepts and it really
shouldn't just be a kind of a linear
progression dependent on someone's age
or what grade they're on it should be a
it should be kind of a this two
dimensional graph based on whether
people have proficiency in a concept and
so you know once you know negative you
know adding multiplying and dividing
negative numbers then you're ready to do
fractions you're ready to do exponents
you know once you write you do basic
exponents then you're ready for geometry
and level 2 exponents you needed
exponents for geometry because you know
PI R squared so that's why you needed R
squared that's an exponent so that's why
you need to have mastery of this first
and you could imagine if you went to
geometry class you have a great geometry
teacher and and she says that the area
of a circle is PI R squared but you
really didn't understand exponents well
you're just gonna be lost no matter what
how good the teacher is and the geometry
teacher often they don't have the time
or it's just not obvious to them that
that the weakness isn't though not in
the understanding the formula but in
understanding the actual math mechanics
of the formula but anyway this is our
knowledge map our our goal is really to
just keep on going I mean I eventually
want branches that go into philosophy
and and law I mean we you know we
already have stuff that are touching on
physics it goes it's it's going close to
calculus now our video library is much
deeper it goes into things that are well
into kind of a quantitative engineering
course load I mean it starts up out here
but it goes into fairly deep concepts
and economics and finance and all the
rest but our goal is that our knowledge
map and our the web module also does the
same eventually we actually want to
create this into an open platform
actually I'll do that in the next video
this cube R Airy is you know a lot of
people the perception is the Khan
Academy it's mainly math and science and
that's what it is right now because I
think that is where the biggest need is
and that is in my opinion what really
doesn't power people or a lot of people
get demoralized the most but this right
here is a is a is a screenshot of
something I'm working on right now
called the cube R and it's essentially
to create kind of a worldwide study
group where you know I have my account
and I can create questions it's kind of
a question o pedia where you know i
essentially i create a flashcard
where I can create a question let's say
you know i'm an AP american history i
pick the category this is the screen
that where i'm actually creating the
question and the choices and i
categorize it within the AP American
history syllabus and then someone else
later on if they want to learn about AP
American issue and I don't have to be a
student that could be a teacher writing
questions they'll see the question and
they'll it'll be ask them the question
and and then you rate it and the idea
here is that obviously not every some
people going to write great questions
some people are gonna write not-so-great
questions
but when you have enough users and
enough questions the database people
will rate the questions by difficulty
importance and quality and then the good
questions will surface to the top and it
really doesn't take much to have a
really valuable database of questions
and really any topic I mean this is
history we could do it in biology
chemistry and it's it's really trivial
to add new concepts there so this is you
know just a you know I gave some of the
I guess you could call them you know
there's some of the letters from from
people who and you know benefited and
it's been kind of overwhelming for me
and very moving for me to see the impact
from the video library but this is a
letter I got literally just yesterday
morning from a student who used the web
app and I want to read out the whole
thing because it's just you know it's
salad just wanted to personally thank
you for everything you've done I'm 23
and was well and you know this I this
letter in caps lays I think a lot of
what Khan Academy is all about I'm 23 I
was home-schooled poorly I might add so
I never had a great education and I've
jumped from awful job to awful job since
I graduated in quotes at 17 and I think
a lot of a lot of us graduate in quotes
right I've always wanted to go to school
for electrical engineering but never
thought it was possible I decided to
give it a shot anyway and started
studying for my a CTS about a month ago
after numerous confusing books I was
almost ready to give up until I stumbled
upon one of your videos on YouTube from
there I went to your website and started
the adaptive math program in the LAT in
the past two weeks I've made it all the
way up to limits of a function which is
pretty but it doesn't go a lot further
he's pretty much almost done he said
that and will soon be done with the
entire program I signed up to take my AC
T's on June 13th and decided to take a
full timed practice test last night and
I scored a 25 that's that's a quite a
good score in the AC T yet I don't know
what percentile that is but it's in the
eighty eighty eighth or ninth 90th
percentile the score required for
admission to CSU
this is Colorado State I don't know
engineering program is 23 so he already
made the cut for that I never thought
that was possible and I still have
almost two months to continue studying
just wanted to again thank you for your
help
you're an inspiration well you know Ryan
I'm on telly on this is what it's about
I you know what did it take me this this
was the the incremental cost to society
was zero right he might have been doing
this while I was sleeping the videos
already out there but the the
incremental benefit I mean obviously to
him it's a huge incremental benefit but
even to society the incremental benefit
I you know I I have no doubt Ryan will
become an electrical engineer and you
know at a minimum he's going to design
great products and make the next
generation of computers and electronics
and maybe he'll invent you know the next
generation transistor or go to Intel and
make processor sentient or you know
hopefully we won't be controlled by
computers and anyway I don't want to go
too far off but I mean this is what gets
me excited in and it reminds me the
leverage of this model is if you really
do have this kind of virtual
infrastructure this virtual education
really motivated people can you know a
self-motivated people can go out there
and educate themselves and and there's
nothing that they're kind of lacking and
it it's free and it should be free
because it costs us nothing and that's
why I you know I general have a little
bit of a problem with charging for
knowledge right and I'll do a whole
another video on on the on the textbook
industry anyway x5b in my economics a
lot of you know where's kind of cannon
be going you know this is I've already
talked about this is the this that right
there that's the video library and the
idea what the video libraries just keep
going you know I say I I want to record
videos until I get hit by a bus you know
I do have a day job I need to you know
feed my family essentially I mean it's
you know I've been privileged I have I
have a good day job so but I you know
this is my joy in life so I I do run a
record these videos until you know
hopefully it's a long time from now
until the day I die and it's you know
not only is it satisfying to get those
those letters like I got I mean it's
it's amazing to think that people in
future generations could learn from this
and there's just a part of me I love
kind of being that person that gets to
go out there you know right now I'm
reading books on relativity which Frank
you know I I learned it in school but I
don't
learnt really really really well and I
it's like a privilege I can go and
digest a bunch of books on relativity
and then I can distill it on the Khan
Academy in a way that it can kind of be
communicated to a lot more people so
it's just it's just a fun thing to do to
spend a lot of your time and and it's um
it's motivating right it's it's
motivating in school you're motivated to
learn for tests but now I'm motivated to
learn new things so that I can you know
hopefully distill them and and share
them with a lot of other people so
that's the video librarian the video
library is kind of linked with the web
app and the idea what the web app is to
keep making modules and you know the
idea is to kind of create a platform
here where other people can also create
modules independently so you know you
can imagine a world to 20 or 30 years
ago from now where there's a module on
every single concept so no one who wants
practice if no one wants to learn
something there's going to be a video on
it and maybe there'll be several videos
and I also like to take a point I don't
think I'm the only person who could do
this I'm trying to find other people who
could do this I want to translate this
into other languages or have someone do
these in other languages because you
know someone might learn well for me but
they my style might not be perfect for
everyone and they could learn better
from someone else and we're keeping
track of the analytics to actually see
where you learn from and who's learning
better from what person so you know this
video library could end up being in the
tens of thousands of people and in every
language I mean you could imagine the
impact if you did it in Spanish and
Arabic and and and Hindi and Mandarin
you'd have a huge worldwide impact I
mean if you want to fight the war on
terror you do this in Arabic and I
guarantee you you're going to have a
more enlightened Muslim world and you'll
have fewer I guess well anyway I don't
want to go I don't wanna make too much
of a of a I'm a social statement wait
wait we have the cube rarey this is kind
of for the things that you know the the
the knowledge you know we talked about
information versus knowledge this is
kind of you know you need to know your
American history you should know some
basic facts and this is where the cube
area comes into play and you know this
will also works for things some things
like biology some concepts in biology
chemistry will be here where you need to
practice some concepts you know what are
the stages of mitosis would be here and
this is something that I'm just starting
to work on and I'm trying it out with
some kids but I want to do a lot of
simulation based learning because I
think that's where you really get
hands-on knowledge especially things
like market simulation strategy
simulations you know I could just be
game playing
a whole set of things and you know we'll
just keep brainstorming more and more
simulations and then this is the thing
I'm really excited about and I'm
starting on this in the next few months
is to really create you know these are
the resources for an individual student
can come or at least these first three
an individual student can come in and
get an education from the system right
the system is the you know the cloud
people say is just giving them an
education but the real power is where
you have a students who students who
learn the basic concepts from here but
after a while students still need you
know the human touch you can't ever get
rid of it but you have all these
students who have knowledge I mean there
could be a let me change the color just
because I think it's there could be a
kid in in Iran who really knows his
algebra and then there could be a kid in
Israel who needs help with algebra and
this kid in Iran could be a great
teacher I mean I'm of the believer that
you know you can improve as a teacher
but great teachers are great teachers
when they're 13 and they might become a
better teacher when they're 30 or 40 or
50 but but they're they're kind of born
so this kid might be a great teacher and
he could tutor this kid in Israel the
same way that I tutored Nadia through a
kind of a trusted virtual school so they
both have this infrastructure right
there and then they can kind of schedule
with each other and use the kind of
virtual classroom to you know kids
around the world are teaching to each
other and it's this kid in Israel still
you know this kid in Iran helped him but
it's still not good enough and he's of
rank for maybe he can find another kid
in in I don't know in England who's of
rank five who can explain a little bit
better and you have a rating system
where you you there's there's an
infinite number of free resources of
people who are willing to help you out
and you know that doesn't just help the
help be that helps to help her because
I'm convinced that the best way to learn
something is to actually teach it and
eventually things get escalated so if
you contribute a lot to the system then
you can get more from the system and you
can get direct instruction from you know
the senior instructors whether it's
myself or other members of the Khan
Academy so that's really where I see it
all going and you know and eventually
even in these villages like obeah Uganda
and those villages in Ethiopia it's five
to ten years before they have broadband
access it's going to happen and
everyone's going to be networked and you
can imagine I mean I use these countries
on purpose because if you got tutoring
from a kid in Iran or the irani kid got
tutoring from a kid in Israel when those
kids become leaders or that least become
influential in their own societies
they're not going to hate each other so
there has other repercussions above and
beyond just you know the notion that
everyone will learn and and and you have
this just in general enlightening of
society anyway you know that's kind of
you know I probably went longer than I
wanted to do but these are where you can
get the other resources khanacademy.org
and at our YouTube Khan Academy Channel
and I'm very open to kind of ideas and a
lot of you know the videos are are you
know people send me emails and say hey
can you do a video on statistics or this
and that that's where they come from so
I'm very open to any feedback you might
have or any ideas and anyway I hope you
found this presentation useful